qui se targue d'instaurer un croquerait
qui n'en est pas un et toujours inscrit
au calendrier législatif il toujours à
l'agenda et les décompositions ô combien
néfaste pour la famille et pour la
société
ce projet de loi les doute qu'un
condensé de mesures qui détruisent la
paternité et la maternité et qui vivre
le corps humain à l'avidité des marchés
financiers alors j'ai gagné aujourd'hui
nous ne trouvons pas n'importe où nous
sommes place vendôme devant l'hôtel de
bourvallais devant le ministère de la
justice
la chancellerie un lieu symbolique qui
doit être le garant de la justice dans
ce pays
nous nous adressons particulièrement aux
nouveaux ministres monsieur dupont
moretti
monsieur le ministre soyez à la hauteur
de votre charge dépend dé la justice
relance et à l'injustice de ce projet
ce projet de loi n'a rien de bio ni des
tic
il est anti tiques toute la culture le
dos des personnes en souffrance de ne
pas avoir d'enfants nous refusons d'être
complice de ce mépris des droits de
l'enfant d'avoir un père et maire de ce
mépris de la paternité et de la
maternité de cet acharnement contre la
famille disney nous sommes là
aujourd'hui quelques détails
[Applaudissements]
general motors en france l'humain ne
supporte pas et moi j'ai un roman au
fond
[Applaudissements]
on ne sort pas
chers amis quelques consignes ils
demandent une journée de votation merci
mister défini leurs gentils courante
déroulement de cette manifestation
aucune forme d'irrespect et de violence
à l'égard de quiconque n'est tolérée
merci de ne pas répondre en cas de
contre manifestations nous gardons le
sourire et je les fais de tout platel y
compris qu'ils chargeaient le congé dans
un souci d'unité
merci de me prendre uniquement les
slogans et trous pour diffuser largement
les fasse respecter les coupes les
distances auto landais et portez votre m
vous le savez il ya aussi une pétition
par abreu qui a été signée déjà par des
milliers de personnes des dizaines de
milliers de personnes mais un peu perdu
donc vous pouvez la signer dès
aujourd'hui soit dans les points
signature sur cette place ou encore plus
simplement
le téléphone qui tapait mesopinions.com
et vous allez tomber sur cette pétition
signée a fait la signer partagez la sur
vos apps facebook avec votre grand mère
il faut que nous soyons nombreux enfin
un appel aux dons vous le savez chaque
prestation un coup nous vous remercions
par avance de l'accueil que vous
réserverez aux bénévoles qui vont passer
tout à l'heure et qui vont solliciter
votre générosité
nous avons besoin de votre soutien pour
défendre la famille et vous le voyez
aujourd'hui nous sommes entourés de
bijoutiers de joaillier adaptez vous à
cet environnement
soyez de l'auteur de ce fait une part et
triple h 30 au merci pour de télé
réalité pour commencer notre
manifestation
chers amis je vous propose de débuter
avec un point d'étape sur le projet de
loi
où en sommes nous vous savez peut-être
mais dans la nuit du 31 juillet au 1er
août en plein milieu de l'été
dans un hémicycle à peine rempli
les députés ont voté ce projet de loi en
seconde lecture ils ont voté pour un
texte en s'asseyant complètement sur les
modifications apportées par le sénat
et malgré les demandes répétées de
l'opposition la majorité a
catégoriquement refusé un vote solennel
pour clore cette seconde lecture ceci
illustre l'obstination du gouvernement
et la légèreté sa majorité parlementaire
cela confirme sa volonté de passer en
catimini un texte éminemment sensible et
clivant profiter de la crise sanitaire
de la crise économique et du creux de
l'été pour avancer en douce sur un sujet
aussi grave est une honte
vous le voyez nous manifestons masqué
signes d'une vie démocratique dégrader
alors nous nous opposons à ce projet de
loi où en sommes-nous sur les toits sur
les trois points pardon principaux la
procréation d'abord les députés ont
refusé d'inscrire nul n'a de droit à
l'enfant
ce faisant ils reconnaissent donc ce
droit c'est une honte
dites-leur c'est une honte
laver les mains pour les couples de
femmes et femmes seuls a été votée le
rebond seulement de la bm à son père et
le remboursement de l'auto conservation
des gamètes par la sécurité sociale a
été votée comme la double filiation
maternelle
klassen qui accouchent comme mère et
l'autre par la déclaration de la part la
déclaration devant notaire a été votée
la double filiation internet et proactif
pour les couples qui ont fait gpa à
l'étranger pourra être reconnu au cas
par cas c'est une haute volée où la
procréation maintenant sur la recherche
l'élargissement de la recherche sur
l'embryon a été voté l'autorisation de
créer des embryons congelés ni qui a été
votée par les actionnaires
l'autorisation de créer des embryons
chimay dic a été votée pour le
diagnostic prénatal et 10 mg le maintien
du bébé médicament a été votée pour
liège et la suppression du délai d'une
semaine - de réflexion a été votée et 10
mg accessible motifs et des traits
psychosocial jusqu'au neuvième mois a
été votée les enfants sont massés
alors j'ai mis des fonds mobilisés car
nous avons quand même obtenu quelques
victoires
en effet la pma pour les transsexuels a
été rejetée on peut sans messe mêlant là
vers mac os martel a été rejetée
cette technique qui consiste à faire
porter par une femme l'ovule fécondé une
autre femme a heureusement été rejetée
le dpa le diagnostic préimplantatoire
qui a traqué les anomalies
chromosomiques a été rejetée et enfin il
n'y aura pas de retranscription
systématique des filiations d'attention
cela a été rejeté mais ça c'est encore
possible au cas par cas alors il faut
continuer le combat et la démotivation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voudrait-on dont il voir vraiment varane
a gagné les rangs thierry sodium
des torrents rappelé aux pays dont on
veut pas falloir tiago star
gbagbo
ça va
oh
la peau
[Applaudissements]
ah oui pardon
à
non
un bateau
[Applaudissements]
alors chers amis il ne sommes pas seuls
à manifester aujourd'hui puisque la
mobilisation et national il y à des
manifestations dans 60 villes en france
c'est un immense succès c'est comme ça
que nous trois nous dirigeants que nous
voulons le retrait de ce projet de loi
il y à des manifestations à grenoble
saint brieuc amène dans cette brève
gaulle à bayonne
et aussi ceux de thann bertagna bourges
plus tôt limoges chargement de votre
centième tour bondi tous
denis clermont ferrand orléans et voxan
france chambéry terre nous emmène à xi
aussi cognac car que l'ebit non dit non
dijon mon maître des lieux le mans
[Applaudissements]
m
ma vie
ce n'est pas moi
[Applaudissements]
accu
général derrière guitare adjoint et
coordinatrice des services et coûte
d'ailleurs ce métal je vous remercie
lundi qu'allez-vous
chers amis si nous sommes mobilisés
aujourd'hui c'est pour alerter les
français sur les graves dérives de cette
loi bioéthique qui nous concerne tous et
qui fait courir des grands dangers pour
les générations futures
le nouveau premier ministre et le
président de la république ont voulu se
débarrasser de ce texte en plein été
dans la nuit du 31 juillet au 1er août
alors que notre pays était confronté à
tant d'urgences politique économique
sanitaire et social les français ont été
mis hors jeu privée d'informations sur
certaines mesures qui n'avait pas jamais
été inscrite dans le projet de loi ni
débattu dans les phase de consultation
on a joué avec le fonctionnement de la
démocratie et ancien moquer de nous on a
surtout ignoré miellé piétiner l'intérêt
des plus fragiles
le texte totalement remaniée en seconde
lecture n'a été
t'es pas 60 députés sur 577
ce texte pas à côté de trois grands
immense qui devrait être trois grandes
causes nationales d'abord la véritable
lutte contre l'infertilité l'arrêt de
l'engrenage eugéniste et enfin le
respect de l'intégrité de l'espèce
humaine
c'est toi crée des injustices et des
discriminations à rebours des impératifs
écologiques avec une procréation
toujours plus artificiels qu'ils
cautionnent un droit à l'enfant avec
cette peña son père qui bouleverse la
filiation rendant la paternité
optionnelle avec ce double don de
gamètes dont on ne parle pas mais qui va
jusqu'à promouvoir la fabrication de
deux enfants privés de toutes origines
mais aussi la congélation des ovocytes
de douane jeunes pour une hypothétique
maternité par tes mains qui est risqué
pour la santé des
je veux dire car pas de plus a été
franchi cet été avec la possibilité
verre conservés et connectées mais
gannett par des établissements lucratif
et là c'est vraiment la porte ouverte
comme hachette de la procréation
discrimination aussi
avec des possibilités de sélection a eu
des enfants à naître
y compris sur des critères génétiques
maintenant encore telle contradiction
avec la politique de société inclusive
que le gouvernement prétend développer
en bazar des personnes en situation de
handicap comment oser leur dire les yeux
dans les yeux
prenez tout votre place dans la société
et en étant leur faire comprendre que
tout est fait pour les empêcher de nerfs
karabatic
[Musique]
d'accord
maintenant
[Musique]
m
et
plus la crise et
elle nous avait bien conscience que des
quel est avantagé
la présence
la prochain
la vie
at il ajouté
est ce que c'est le cas des redevances
khattak
de la défense
7 je
les coudes l'électrochoc qui étaient des
personnes choquées hallyday
résultat
l'écart
ça a pris deux
la réponse à ce décret
il est soulagé
et s'imposer
cet or est extrême
et
[Musique]
ce type de proposition
vous les bras tout seul
[Applaudissements]
m les craintes
c'est pourquoi sa maman
dans ses conclusions à prendre ses
responsabilités
il ya un côté son projet
je le rappelle à ses amis
pour
passé
allez décider
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
l'effort
nous vendons pas
[Applaudissements]
m
en clair
jardiner nous avons privatisé tout bien
place pendant cette manifestation
il est important de pommes s'agglutiner
devant mme et occuper tout l'espace
petit cadavre
merci de votre nez fait à leur abandon
en tout ce beau tableau exactement très
bien failli être importuné place pour
bien d'occuper tout un plat est
repositionné sur l'écran rester dans
l'existence fêter la distanciation
sociales versées alors à tout seigneur
tout honneur et le seigneur des
seigneurs c'est monsieur milliers de la
justice en regardant les vidéos de ses
interventions sur ce projet de loi vous
et nous conseillons mais seulement être
d'en faire autant et de se regarder nous
le découvrons en vidéo
monsieur le garde des sceaux vous ne
vous moquez nous l'a sérieusement
franchement c'est un manque de respect
part au débat qui redonne à la
franchement d'or s'est passé avant le
dews ici devant toute la représentation
nationale à soutenir votre imaginaire
d'une particulière fertilité toute la
représentation nationale
je veux dire deux choses
hier c'est que la question de vous poser
très strictement rien d'avoir une bonne
idée et la deuxième c'est qu'ils sont
quand même bêche imaginez qu'un jeu
puisse décider femmes enceintes de
vienne aut
voilà je débute et ce que je voulais le
gouvernement est défavorable à votre
ah ben non
[Musique]
mr debré favorable à votre
c'est la concision juridique
oui je vais évoquer les dispositions des
articles 371-4 63,5 10-3 373 tirer 2-9
360 15-5
et quand nous aurons ensemble heureux lu
ces textes pour comprendre et les
raisons pour lesquelles gouvernement est
défavorable
la filiation autrefois c'était papa et
maman
la filiation le charme elle est fondée
sur l'intégrité sexuelle
[Musique]
breux
rentrez les domaines c'est pourquoi j'ai
donc un avis défavorable à ces zones d
un ami à définir éternité que tu marcel
pagnol d'une chose la vraisemblance
biologique monde 20 c'est quand même peu
vraisemblable sas est frappé au coin du
bon sens patience et longueur de temps
font plus que force ni que large d'une
seconde ne soyez pas impatients
[Musique]
bravo monsieur le ministre ces pépites
retrouver du bon sens monsieur le
ministre c'est sans doute notre
protestation mais non
[Applaudissements]
oh
j'aime me on le sait et on le redit
encore la famille est un lieu
extraordinaire de solidarité et de
protection
or depuis de nombreuses années
l'individualisme créé la solitude et
fait le malheur de beaucoup chacun son
petit bonheur sa petite fille ont des
choses et tant pis pour les autres
ce projet de loi s'il était voté
reporterait l'individualisme en coupant
les liens fondamentaux du l'enfant et en
se basant uniquement sur le désir
individuel
les lions des enfants à leurs parents
sont charnelle psychique affective et
cultuel tout cela ne peut pas être
remplacé par le seul désir que se
passera-t-il si les fameux parents
d'intention ne désire plus leurs enfants
nous connaissons la fragilité d'un
contrat un enfant ne peut pas être
l'objet d'un contrat un enfant n'est pas
un objet que l'on peut acheter ou vendre
combien de fois faudra t il écrit au
départ
combien de fois l'être humain est un
être de relations étaient liés aux
fondamentaux familiaux sont essentiels
tout le look de sa vie relate ce qui
fait le ciment de notre société
voilà ce qui fait le coeur de la
solidarité des agrégés des liens et
considérer qu ils ne sont rien c'est
emmener vers nous emmener vers une
société fait d'individus isolés
seuls face à leurs difficultés
cette loi en s'attaquant à la filiation
détruit le coeur de la fraternité
albert camus dans ses lectures au peuple
de france disait de nombreuses
générations ont cru que leur mission
était de refaire le monde
la nôtre devrait donner pour mission
d'éviter qu'ils ne t'est des femmes est
ce que vous voulez que le monde ce n'est
pas tout
j'aidais mon drapeau montrer notre
détermination enfin l'inter milan en
france les achètent pas aux larmes
nous cellou enfants nés entre la fin
entre l'homo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tél
ce jour
je le rencontrais des six mois était
partante mais le voyage je prendrai
et moi j'étais quoi cheveux qui m'ont
appris qu'il n'y a pas d'heure
interdite
oui
du plateau que je
pour moi tu es
avant tout
jésus-christ
maintenant en tournée à quel rythme
ici c'est le même pour tous génération
[Applaudissements]
je vais
les jours
[Musique]
harry
non
[Applaudissements]
après pour téléphone est éteint
le
il trompe
mais non pour comprend toujours vu les
devants quasi être ignorants j'avais vu
y aura six lettres par tous les journaux
je le faisais nous avons décidé tous
notre devise trop gênant du mettrait pas
fin 2001
notre génération et raffinée d'un
mouvement d'un an
aujourd'hui les jeunes c'est l'occasion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la saint jean qui se bat au quotidien
pour empêcher les projets de leurs amis
les pommes les huit ans que nous aurions
nous attendait mais nous avons eu
plusieurs occasions de faire entendre
notre voix
nous avons pu rencontrer le président en
personne
en février dernier il nous a dit que
nous faisons ces débats bon d'accord et
que le droit de vtt était fondamentale
commise par la marque
sans enfant était interdit de manifester
le mardi suivant
nous devrions aujourd'hui député en
métal au nom de tous les yeux de la
manif pour tous
monsieur le président nous sommes
aujourd'hui sur ce podium pour dénoncer
au nom de notre génération et de la
génération future
le retrait pur et simple de ce projet de
loi
mignon vous ne semblez pas capables
d'une écoute crier ni de dialogue comme
on a pu le voir avec les états généraux
ou la bureautique
[Musique]
tu lui semblait en effet pas qu avatar
est actuellement un des vocal et à
baiser que je sois par le passage de la
loi en juillet ou pas toutes les
semaines des as tué
nous jeunes demandons un monde plus
juste et mieux négocié négocie centré
sur l'humain respectueux de ses trois
des plus d'infos temps
nous attirons qu'aucune étude sérieuse
des scientifiques ne permet de prétendre
qu'ils venaient tous deux devront passer
en tête
nous avons besoin que chacun a son
histoire et de récits ne peuvent être
planifiées à l'avancé en supprimant
certains n'ont même jamais nous jeu des
longs l'arrivée de lavage sur le sol
français avec ou sans désir d'enfant qui
s'est tenue il ya quelques semaines
trouve mon gouvernement
la gta
yudhoyono le trafic international
d'êtres humains qui en découlent
monter nous appelons désormais tous les
jeunes de france qui pensent que le père
aussi humain soit il et que la mère ou 6
km soit elles sont deux éléments
essentiels pour la vie de l'enfant
tous les jeunes qui considèrent que la
loi et la sphère de tous
de nouveaux politiques de toutes
convictions à nous rejoindre pour total
et romain
nous n'aurons que nous avons raison
comme je l'aimé
et que nous sommes la vie dit les droits
de l'homme et de l'enfant
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes tous nos jeux
[Musique]
alors chers amis maintenant nous allons
reprendre et le coutume popularisé par
l'équipe d'islande de foot par d'une
coupe du monde avec un gigantesque
klepping tout ça du coup je vais vous
demander
on voyait venir de continuer à vous
espaces et bien au fond d'occuper tout
l'espace
c'est un signe symbolique nous prenons
la place nous voulons nous faire
entendre
ce cabinet simple vous que les principes
pour manifester votre position vous
clapet et du grenier suis dit est ce que
tout le monde est bien les bras écartés
[Applaudissements]
attention silence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que le ministre nous entendre
d
tiéné
à
j'étais sans danger
alors nous avons plus chers amis nous
avons vu en vidéo les pépites de
monsieur le ministre de la justice
nous allons découvrir en vidéo les
interventions du nouveau ministre de la
santé monsieur olivier ferrand qui
répète à l'envi qu'il ya des progrès qui
n'en sont pas et bien montrer le nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous parlez jamais de cela
il faut les soirs
entend préserver
le texte jeudi
j'habitais de chant
pierre antique gps navigation non
discriminante au bugle pour nos sexuelle
de ce qui se fait beau aujourd'hui tous
les jours
[Musique]
jean maurice
il existe certes un vieux sage 40
c'est un moment pour tout ce que les
démarches de dispenser des carrières
je
six mois et fort que des fins
d'utilisation est mené deux volontés
survivante de réparer stopper un profil
à nous souhaitons autorisée l'autre
devant de la tête
une fois deux fois
raisonnable une loi d
tous droits
france des droits
je dis ma classe
à l'époque
du
[Musique]
une barre
oui
[Musique]
c'est une loi qui émane
[Applaudissements]
nous ne maintenant accueillir neutre
c'est un conte intervenant en avocat
maître grégoire démons qui va lui donner
un regard juridique non piété sur ce
projet de loi je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
chers amis c'est un mois le plus jeune
des avocats qu'ils regardent aujourd'hui
de m'adresser au plus célèbre des
coffrets eric dupond moretti est devenu
le garde des sceaux
[Applaudissements]
et du mouvement ethic tous les avocats
voulu pendant sa carrière
le recours des faire devant les
tribunaux la voix des sans voix
alors pourquoi une fois devenu garde des
sceaux salettis revoir nos priorités de
priver les enfants de leur père qui est
le recours naturel des enfants pourquoi
fallait-il avoir pour priorité des tarés
pour toujours la voix des sans voix par
excellence que sont les enfants à m
depuis quand l'injustice était la
promesse de la misère avons nous oublié
à ce point ce qu'était le droit ce
qu'est le droit avant le droit
il y en a nous et en particulier ses
amis fécond qui sont à l'origine du
monde l'amour de l'homme et de la femme
l'amour des parents pour leurs enfants
l'amour
c'est une extase s'est littéralement
rester en dehors de soi s'oublier pour
autrui l'amour est l'autre nom de la
liberté et c'est une liberté qui oblige
à la fragilité humaine est telle que
malgré toute leur puissance de séduction
ses amours de l'homme et de la femme des
parents et de l'enfant sont menacés et
c'est pour les protéger que de tout
temps on a inventé le droit
la raison d'être du droit c'est d'unir
les hommes c'est de restituer que le
faible et le fort l'égalité qui fait de
la justice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la victoire est essentielle était la
civilisation du 3 sur la faiblesse
humaine c'est le mariage de mariage en
chasse l'amour de l'homme et de la femme
dans les biens d'égalité de mariage en
chasse l'amour des parents pour leurs
enfants dans les liens de la
responsabilité
hier tout au logement le droit romain
est investi la règle suivante il france
conceptus l'enfant conçu et réputé mais
chaque fois que c'est dans son intérêt à
ce petit homme incapable de se défendre
ont donné un statut une protection comme
s'il était déjà mais comme s'il faisait
déjà partie de la grande famille des
hommes
[Applaudissements]
cette civilisation de la liberté de
justice d'amour nos pères l'ont dit
j'arrête
elle s'appelle plus grands hélas m eur
sur monsieur fictive du désir de jouir
sans entraves
arrive un jour où l'autre mon frère
devient une chaîne une entrave à
réjouissance
on veut donc faire l'homme séparer ces
chaires ont les cartes pour le marchand
ou le tube ce soir je jouais au
détriment d'autrui
ce bar et douloureux liberté d'amour
nous les deux réalités que le règne de
la force et mais a pas d'amour à la
justice on brise l'amour fou entre
l'homme et la femme on a détruit maria
aujourd'hui il s'agit d'instaurer à
travers les mailles la gpa
selon les mots de jean louis tourenne la
procréation sexe cela signifie la
séparation des sexes voir la guerre des
sexes au nom d'un mensonge
institutionnel d'une séparation
artificielle corps et de l'esprit les
femmes pourront faire semblant d'avoir
des enfants sans hommes et les hommes
père semble en avoir des enfants sans
femmes
et je tuer le père c'est fun il faut
éliminer les hommes dit alice coffin
oh
on brise aussi la noue entre les noirs
et les enfants en supprimant comme vous
le savez le bel est ce parce que la
gratuité pour la famille est exigeante
conneries substituer aux aujourd'hui le
commerce
et oui c'est tellement plus facile
l'évasion commerciale sont uniquement
fondé sur l'intérêt commun des
cofacteurs on échange d'une chose contre
une autre que le convoitent encore
auprès des relations commerciales
il suffit d'y mettre le prix ah l'amour
qui fait l'homme et la cité nous
substituons donc à marcher longtemps et
l'on achète des hommes réduits au rang
de fournisseur de sperme et femmes
ravalez votre rôle de fournisseur de
sites et de ventres à louer des enfants
faux lui non plus pour eux mêmes mais
que le bonheur pour mentir
insensiblement l'enfant devient un droit
de dire la part revenant à la butte
suivante à mes véritables mécanismes de
suggestions et de chosification et c'est
ainsi que l'on arrive à l'estomac
c'est l'article 221-1 du club finale
définition légale la réduction en
esclavage et le fait d'exercer à
l'encontre d'une personne
l'un des attributs du droit de propriété
risque lavage la négation même du droit
murs y sommes
[Applaudissements]
voilà quelle est la libération curieux
ferons nous prouver voilà tout en mesure
et en équilibre que nous propose le
gouvernement
elle aboutit à l'east ravages en
attendant que la technique permettra les
usines à bébés du meilleur des mondes
chadli face à cette fin de droits qui
annonce la fin de la civilisation la fin
de l'amour vet notre espérance dans
plusieurs de ses livres certains sera
d'avoir eu raison avant tout le monde
alors ne lâchez rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
celle là
puisque les ministres sont sourds nous
en appelons au président de la
république monsieur président de la
république ou n'est que vers vous
quelles sont vos priorités au service de
qui est mou est dû au service des
français dans leur ensemble ou bien avec
vous au service des idéologues
déconnecté du réel des puissances de
l'argent qui cherche à établir des
nouveaux marchés sur le dos de l'humain
de certains scientifiques qui se
conduisent en apprenti sorcier vous lui
disiez vouloir rassembler les français
et pourtant la quasi-totalité de la
france est dans la rue sous votre mandat
les gilets jaunes des paysans les
avocats
soignant les pompiers les russes et les
étudiants et chercheurs et familles
aisées
[Applaudissements]
dans les familles hôtes et ce même à lui
que vous avez souhaité ce projet de loi
vous avez fait remis qu'en france on
arrive à imaginer mais c'est pas de
panne
elle va fouet le premier droit des
enfants celui tout connaître et d'être
élevé dans la mesure du possible par son
père et sa mère joue président de la
république vous ne vous ne donnez pas la
suppression des droits qui monte des
plus faciles
je vais
coc
[Applaudissements]
deux états comment pouvez vous faire du
mal à vous questionner cette négation
des droits des pucelles ce mépris du
père
[Applaudissements]
c'est un feeling that matter net
maternité sont essentiels pour le fond
ils doivent être
il dit
oui
[Applaudissements]
tant de plus rempli de 10
je dis stop
après tout même de diestar
vivement de la femme allégations de la
beauté de la patrie
[Applaudissements]
du président français
lucas ne brièvement ce pilier fondateur
est supportable
il monsieur le président devant leurs
familles le premier lieu de la
solidarité
on l'a bien vu pendant le confinement en
prétendant créer une nouvelle filiation
en dire l'importance essentielle de la
réalité en faisant miroiter les mirages
de l'auto conservation des gamètes de
l'affiliation à fait semblable vous
continuer à porter atteinte à venir
j'avais même osé dire
et pas forcément mal mais reprenez vos
esprits
[Applaudissements]
et si vous prétendez ses sourires alors
comment
les enfants les jeux de tout depuis les
spectateurs
sur le président les générations futures
vous demanderont des comptes soit dit le
président qui rassemble retirer ce
projet et famille les amoureux de la
justice de l'égalité et la liberté vous
regardent soit gulf à la hauteur
[Applaudissements]
non
soir
à mâcon
je suis
jégo
[Musique]
enfin
non
mais bon
à renfort
autre
non
c'est
[Musique]
hélas
à
il
sarah
moi
je vais bras
le
la vie
les gains
et en
je ne parle
[Applaudissements]
les
je vais
[Applaudissements]
m
et
[Musique]
marcher elle y parle au business dans
mon business cd donnant parce que c'est
au nom de l'amour qu'ils font tout cela
est ici à bourrer marché semble plutôt
faire bon ménage
ok sur les boer a priori s'est
désintéressé mais le marché de la
procréation lui n'est pas désintéressée
c'est un business mondial colossal en
2019 18,3 milliards de dollars 18 degrés
[Applaudissements]
en croissance constante il génère des
profits énormes et c'est bien là l'un
des objectifs du projet doit évidemment
la consumer donc à un marché
honteux inhumain des promoteurs de la
paix mais à de laver les mains sans
motif médical
prétendre qu'il n'y aura pas de business
de gamètes puisque la france défend
interdit le principe de non
disponibilité des éléments du corps
humain mais qui peut croire que ce
principe soit respecté une fois la loi
votée
pourquoi parce que le marché est
confronté à un problème le manque de
donneurs
c'est qu'en 2017 il ya eu seulement
quatre cent quatre donneurs qui se sont
manifestés heureusement quand on se dira
il est encore un peu de bon sens et
bonne conscience et les campagnes
d'incitation aux dons soutien efficace
à l'heure actuelle
d'hommes et de femmes doivent attendre
de 1 à 3 ans c'est très long au désert
de fertilité mais si la loi passe la
demande de cadres a explosé et le grand
risque chers amis c'est de transformer
cet honneur en fournisseur c'est à dire
que les gamètes soient rémunérés
jean louis touraine l'un des co
rapporteur du projet de loi s'est
lui-même dit favorable à rémunération
des cannettes
il a passé la reconnaître les truismes
[Applaudissements]
quel sketches cela s'appelle générer le
porno citoyenne
à
il souhaite d'ailleurs que les femmes
qu'il y ait deux types français soient
revus en plaire abandonné alors oui il
est clair que si elle voit passer les
dons de gamètes ne suffirait pas comment
répondre aux besoins sans renier un
principe de la gratuité du don et bien
c'est impossible
d'autres pays ont essayé ça n'a pas
marché ils ont tous commencé à se
fournir auprès de banques de sperme
privé comme cryos internationale
tout s'achète des gamètes ils sont
entrés dans l'engrenage de la
marchandisation des éléments du corps
humain croire que la france à rabat
comme par magie de répondre aux besoins
sans renier ses principes
c'est croire au père noël la force ne
pourra pas fait autrement
et qui dit choix dit catalogue vous le
gagnez la logique du marché est en route
alors en réalité prétendus problèmes
qu'on veut nous imposer aujourd'hui
c'est en fait le profit de demain c'est
un progrès en termes de profits
financiers
[Musique]
et je ne parle pas de science fiction
pourquoi un seul exemple les quatre
essais les 5 et 6 septembre dernier il
ya à peine un mois
un salon s'est tenu à paris qui
s'appelle désir d'enfant qui a rassemblé
rocard exposants agences de pma en tous
genres toujours de générer clinique
générale aussi des transports de gamètes
et d'embryons les services sont
multiples vente de galettes catalogue
d'hommes et de femmes pendant leur
nouveau site ou leur sperme catalogue
mère porteuse choix du sexe skrynnik
génétique élimination et des barres à
des enfants qui ne conviendrait pas
une anecdote dramatique à paris donc
lors de ce salon un couple enquêtant
pour la manif pour tous a demandé
clinique gédé a pris quelques
informations techniques lui a répondu
que si l'enfant commandé par gba de
couvrir à la naissance il pouvait
toujours être renvoyés dans un
orphelinat mais dément
et
c'est toi du président de la conversion
mais bien celle de l'argent et
d'exploitation parce que naturellement
ce marché vaut sur l'exploitation de la
souffrance des personnes qui n'ont pas
d'enfant et l'exploiter culture alors
doivent leur part qu'il entendait vapeur
[Applaudissements]
m
ce n'est pas
et
là
jamais
allez
chers amis puisque les politiques ils
les députés ne sont pas capables de nous
dire tout est ouvert
nous allons les chercher dans notre
culture
oui un truc utile elle éclater la vérité
aussi nous allons vous présenter des
extraits de certains films comme ceux
chez des amis ce chef-d'oeuvre du
célèbre rockeur to believe i la vie est
belle
ensuite nous verrons un battage du
voleur de bicyclette de vittorio de sica
et enfin un grand film que vous
collectez toute star wars optique le
retour du jedi de rigeur d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mbeki
manet
[Musique]
paris
ouais
[Applaudissements]
m
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
oui
prenant vie du vieux 4 c
non
bravo merci au cinéma de défendre le feu
alors j'ai mis un petit rappel des
consignes merci vraiment occuper toute
la place
allez-y souhaite
aucune et vous combien les distances
le port du masque voilà revenez ses
consignes c'est important d'occuper
vraiment tout l'espace maintenant je
vous demande d'accueillir en troisième
intervenant
monsieur bertrand lionel marine il est
avocat métier mais aussi secrétaire
général des associations familiales
catholiques les accès je leur dit elle
rejoindre sur certains logements de sur
scène merci de me le dire
tél
[Musique]
mais qui
lee
et
[Applaudissements]
cher
oui
chez vos amis
pour ceux qui ont suivi les débats dit
de bioéthique
depuis les numéros 126 du 15 juin 2010
est sûre les demandes sociétales de
recours à l'assistance médicale à la
procréation puis à travers les états
généraux de la bioéthique et jusqu'au
vote en seconde lecture à l'assemblée
nationale le 1er août à 3h34 du matin
dans un hémicycle aux quatre cinquième
vide
à
il ya disons le une tentation désespère
désespérée de la capacité du politique
non répondent au désir individuel comme
un distributeur de droit à méjanes
rechercher le bien commun désespérer de
la capacité de la démocratie qui délègue
ses pouvoirs à des sachants et des
experts dont certains ne savent pas même
ce que sont le bien et le mal
désespéré donc de la capacité la
démocratie à mettre des limites aux
techniques devenues folles comme disait
albert camus dans son discours de suède
la limite d'un jour s'efface devant
celle du lendemain et l'éthique varie au
gré des modes et des majorités désespéré
en fin de la capacité des gouttes de
ceux qui nous gouvernent
ils ont des oreilles
deux pas
[Applaudissements]
et tout en jouant
vous attend
nous sommes là devant ce ministère de la
justice pour dénoncer mois a juste
une loi juste qui déconstruit la
bioéthique à la française qu'il est ou
de les embryons humains à la recherche
dérégulé qui fait fi des générations
futures qui réduit l'homme aujourd'hui
et la femme demain à être de simples
fournisseurs de ressources biologiques
dans un grand marché de la chair comme
le dit sylviane agacinsky ses lagons
foire du corps en pièces du corps en
miettes les commerces et
le marché des ovocytes l'accaparement
des embryons par isabeau le marché des
ventres à louer le salon désir d'enfant
ne suffit-il pas 12 ans ne suffit-il pas
à 100 contre 1
[Applaudissements]
oh
les afc reporter une action pour tenter
de faire interdire ce salon elles ont
également un tel talent déposé plainte
contre x pour délit tony zale gpa et
délits de réduction en esclavage
notamment nous sommes là aussi pour
dénoncer une loi indécente indécent en
effet de poursuivre des chimères ou
plutôt d'en fabriquer et de désister
avoir convoqué la médecine et le droit
quand le virus trône
quant au mode de les grandes nations
quand il faudrait inventer les épaves
quand le déficit de l'assurance maladie
se creuse
indice encore de programme et par mois
d'absence de vampires et de pères et de
porter dans le même temps le congé
paternité à 28 jours au motif que 14
jours ne suffisait pas pour moi un lien
suffisant entre l'enfant et le palais
[Applaudissements]
à
indécent enfin de très tendre promouvoir
la concorde et rechercher le consensus
est de donner dans le même temps notre
président mais quand la chef de clan
dégage est prétendument à gauche du
maquereau nisme
injuste dont dix ans donc
mais ce n'est pas tout cette morte est
également guillaume
[Musique]
enfin gagné 1,3 de vie et de mort sur un
enfant à naître et jusqu au terme d'une
grossesse plus vu les traits tendus
détresse citons soutien
sauf que les pater familias arabes
avaient le droit de vie et de mort sur
leurs enfants et que les sites et de
pratiquer l'exposition des nourrissons
est ce vraiment de ce monde là que vous
voulez est ce vraiment de ce monde là
que nous voulons
[Applaudissements]
merci cher monsieur vous cette
intervention
[Applaudissements]
alors si aurélie leur est grave
dramatique ce projet bois qui avance il
veut tuer la paternité
ils veulent planter là pour montrer
notre colère de révolte notre
indignation
[Musique]
nous allons marquer un temps de silence
une minute de silence en hommage à tous
ces enfants qui connaîtront pas le père
merci de respecter cette minute de
silence
aidez nous entendons ensuite un des
loges de la vérité
aujourd'hui un pays ami devenu paie un
statut en voie de disparition
boullier renault left oreilles sont
devenus fous le faiseur de la
psychanalyse a laissé son empreinte
notre mandat bien acté qu'il fallait
pour se construire tuer le père en
seulement voit s'arrêter ce monde et le
progrès se trouvaient les destructions
le père espérait seulement quatre jours
de fabricants de réalité sous le vocable
anesthésiant de mieux éthique et que de
boutoir l'industrie prétendants
fabriquer les humains mon père ce héros
souris acide
nous sommes bien éloigné de l'hommage
fuite de ruraux dans la légende des
siècles
c'est ce poème vous savez après la
bataille cacher le célèbre deux nuits de
même à voir si mon père et de l'opéra
locaux restent at il apprécié ce matin
visant à laisser passer que l'on est le
monde aux enfants perturbés d'avoir été
privé au nom de mes mots ici une figure
paternelle masculine naturel très vite
feliz au feu ap ap articles tous
indignés
la vie divorce maladie gueulant tout
repris mme l'effet of war 4 amélie aux
victimes ne cédera jamais feront
prochainement mes fils et fille cobayes
consulter des chimères au début le
chimérique in your man qu'elle existe
des zones devient capable auprès des
foyers
le shérif rosé rouge d'accueillir des
enfants de leur année afin de les
accompagner de les aimer le père est
président de produits de consommation
faudrait que prévu et fabriquer un air
france info rôle consiste à incarner
dans un premier temps une présence sur
rassurante et protectrice et celui dans
le flou les encouragements ravi ses
analyses visent il devient celui qui en
douce les illusions et qui aurait signé
ou s approche d affection saison au
terme c'est à dire lorsque j'étais
enfant dans son écran
un poisson fin du mois c'est ça votre
recette que prévu les droits seront
sûrement tué à faire c'est aussi ce
génétique traitantes accueillir au seul
motif que le proverbe airs mais ses
partisans réclament
des îles vous renier aujourd'hui à mes
amis est devenu père
c'est une grande joie pour son épouse
pour lui leurs enfants aujourd'hui un
enfant de bénéfices les sourires c'est
fatigués mais heureux ensemble
son père la demi heure un jour
vaincus des quarts
et puis enfin ce sera le tour le père le
néo soul et signe
10 kg native ils se tournent de façon
ils regardent moins un artiste reggae
sont fabriqués ignore s'ils n'ont plus
de père à l'antique de qui tu es et les
sorciers tremblements meilleur ami la
bonne nouvelle c'est que cela n'est pas
fini tant que célébrité
[Applaudissements]
t
le processus législatif est encore long
ne faites pas avait des parties qui
cherchent à croire que c'est terminé
alors que ce n'est pas le cas nous
sommes une immense majorité pour 80% des
français
les enfants nés par pma ont le droit
d'avoir un père et mère
[Applaudissements]
la feuille de paie
ce projet de loi dit louis tic
correspond un choix idéologique
un choix politique à nous le savons en
politique tout peut toujours arriver
rien d'écrit
[Applaudissements]
comme ludivine historien il est battu
non seulement nous ou pour agir
mais new age et autour de nous beaucoup
de français n'ont pas construire 2
cette loi est là c'est moi qu'on leur
fait croire que c'est juste vingt trois
de plus pour légaliser tout cela est un
mensonge
est ce qu'il ya la loi dit que les
paiements des accessoires superflus
seconde est têtu
[Applaudissements]
collectivement nous continuerons
d'intervenir tant que nécessaire
d'autres tg les droits de l'enfant et
des générations à venir
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas une option et la maternité
titrisation n'ont pas perdu tant
souhaité
bon sang
mallet
le vent
à
non pas des animaux
la télé
[Applaudissements]
hu
à
[Musique]
je
à
je l'associé
ap
et
d
j'aimais
jo
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous accueillons maintenant les ennemis
les oboles de la justice de l'atlantique
liberté des visages et des voix de femme
les mariannes
[Applaudissements]
je suis marianne2 fr de france et
aujourd'hui les dirigeants de mon pays
auquel le peuple à côté des donneurs et
le privilège de faire les mois ces élus
ont ce désir fou de nous déposséder
d'une partie de notre humanité
nous les femmes avons besoin des hommes
pour concevoir un enfant comme les
hommes ont besoin de nous
oh
c'est un ferment de notre humanité et de
notre société et nous refusons que
l'allemand l'a juste et pour les gens
pour les citoyens nous refusons
et avis une fiction de filiation faire
croire à nos enfants car vers et tous
passionnés ou accessoires et seulement 6
[Applaudissements]
et
les enfants ils un peu
pendant la présence de lambert et si ces
mêmes parlementaires et tapis d'un congé
paternité obligatoire et à louviers
c'est bien qu'il reconnaisse
l'importance tu fais dans le
développement des enfants un peu
différent s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
je suis morgan ou et je ne suis pas
aveugle
le projet de loi qui va repasser au
sénat contient plusieurs mesures
représentant des menaces graves pour
notre humanité
mais je ne suis pas aveugle certes des
délits suivants corps ont été retirés du
texte parce qu'il fallait tout de même
entendre les opposants je pense
notamment à la pma post mortem à l'arpa
mon corps a lâché un set et clara des
femmes et des enfants déjà ratifié dans
le monde mais je ne suis pas avec tous
les mécanismes préparant les consciences
sont en place pour que ces messieurs
contre dans la loi dite de bioéthique
lors de sa prochaine édition les chaînes
du service public propose des émissions
larmoyante des termes elles se tiennent
paris pour proposer différents tarifs et
différentes options de gpa et circuler
mais derrière cherche à faciliter
toujours plus la reconnaissante des gp a
réalisé à l'étranger
quelle hypocrisie
je ne suis pas aveugle mais je me sens
seul lyon les hommes politiques libres
capables de voir des drames qui se
prépare où sont elles les femmes
politiques libres les vrais féminisme
suppôts des têtes on a filé vers la
femme à quoi bon avoir des 3,6 et pour
pleurer sur un monde qui se défait
[Applaudissements]
je suis marianne et je suis debout je
suis debout parce que la victime se
couchent muzols devant le ministère de
la justice
devons-nous gâteau laver miele effet
plaint que steve
si les résultats sont bien trop pays
encourage la création de filiation
fiction qui ne sont que des huit ans à
la céder plus de l'injustice
un enfant ne peut pas pardonner non un
ensemble ne se conçoit pas que d'une
femme et oui un enfant devient
d'affaires
arrêtez de vous coucher devant des
minorités prête à détruire les
fondements de filiation pour leur
vestiaire personnel mais surtout je suis
devenu part que vous chers d'amis chers
fallu de france est du goût vous qui
vous battez avec nous depuis des
semaines pour alerter pour réveiller les
consciences mais qui sont ils ces
politiciens pour des idées qu'un enfant
ne pillez pas d'avoir de faire ils sont
ils pour décider qu'une faille pour être
loués tel et literie lab qui sont-ils
combats de l'été notre humanité
[Applaudissements]
à l'ats confirmant à dénoncer toutes les
eaux de ce texte
continuons à demander son retrait
intégral pour ne pas vous préservez la
prison nécessaire de nos pères comme de
nos mères
jamais le nous coucherons devant tel
projet de loi nous sommes la jeunesse
l'avenir de notre société
musa de goût de vous nous resterons
[Applaudissements]
oui
a gênés
[Applaudissements]
et
enfin plus
tha
ouah
à toi
quoi
[Applaudissements]
m
à
[Musique]
ça ne s'invente pas
[Applaudissements]
nous accueillons
une intervenante qui vous connaissez
tous qui se bat sans relâche depuis de
nombreuses années pour se poser à ces
lois injustes et inique nous je vous
demande à tonnerre d'applaudissements
pour la présidence de la panique pour
tous une vie de chat
on applaudit lui donner
à
[Applaudissements]
chez sa fille
la france vit une période difficile
douloureuse à certaines à la france et à
tort de tous au moins deux choses de
l'exécutif qu'il se concentre sur les
urgences à commencer par leur santé
physique économique et qu'il veut
l'unité de la société
mais au lieu de cela cet été il s'est
occupé en priorité des sujets hautement
clivant et surtout pas urgent du projet
de loi bioéthique qui est évidemment bio
ni l'éthique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de six ministres et du beau monde attire
participer à ça méchamment la cub de
l'assemblée nationale fin juillet
répondre sur les questions de filiation
il a marmonné ton qu'il était le malaise
[Applaudissements]
et qui intervient souvent de l'absence
de peine et de la souffrance qu'il a
tenus
mais arrivé au pouvoir
c'est la tradition la raison d'être en
forme et la taille des français
[Applaudissements]
honte à vous monsieur le ministre carr
de mercer
oh
[Applaudissements]
c'est ainsi que le premier ministre jean
castex s'est même réjoui de l'issue de
la seconde lecture du projet de loi à
l'assemblée nationale
menaces qui guettent toujours témoigné
de l'importance d'un cent en amérique et
son refuge de ce mot nation de pair avec
ses filles ont débordé dans le cas là me
soutient ce projet de loi
[Applaudissements]
les députés les vous même temps le
premier ministre la principale avec il
pas de projets
demandeur
[Applaudissements]
ce texte n'est encore qu'un projet et
vous
heureusement vous êtes là et nous sommes
saisis à paris tout en france
aujourd'hui pour éclater le vote
définitif de ce projet deux mois
[Applaudissements]
car ce texte porte atteinte aux valeurs
de l'enfance qui se dessine aussi pour
patrie des droits de l'homme comme atout
c'est au lieu de 27 ans de cotisation
pris délibérément des enfants de paix
toute leur vie comment cette affaire
privée de cette relation paternelle
unique
non ce n'est pas possible le comité
consultatif national 10 des dix
décidément que deux mondes éthique et
juridique n'est pas mauvais des tickets
et bien ce cessez le feu pendant des
années que l'enfant a besoin de repères
s'il a changé de ton qui il ya deux ans
ce qui l'a sauvé face à
intérêts financiers il a chuté face à
l'échec parce qu'il a cédé face à
l'idéologie transhumanisme parce qu'il a
cédé face à l'affluence de 12 ans mixtes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
je suis le problème est éthique
wen organisme entièrement constituée
nommé pas l'exécutif dans la dépendance
est une formule contraire de ce qu exige
toute réflexion éthique et voilà le
résultat
un président du cce qui affirme ne pas
faire de différence entre le bien et le
mal
[Applaudissements]
politique de faire passer ce qu'ils
veulent deux raisons politiciennes mais
qui n'assume pas même
casser des propres du cciel qui ont
permis le lancement de ce projet qui ont
signé l'appel race enfin au but sont au
desiderata des médias tron
si la paire d'informatique médicale et
développer un centre et entre
conservation des gamètes sans motif
médical se sauver de l'instauration de
la première sous son sexe pour tous sur
ce n'est la station
rien de distillation de la procréation
se sauver une médicalisation temps
dépassé d'un prétendu écologiste et
féministe chapiteau comme l'ouverture
marché plus mal
la sécurité sociale c'est à dire vous
c'est à dire des français enrichi les
alors tous à vos postes médicaux et
cette relation de l'humain sarthois
pharmaceutique essais cliniques privées
[Applaudissements]
si le trio du séparatisme ne voulut pas
des minorités dans celle disons le csbj
oui
[Applaudissements]
résultat prévisible d'une société où il
n'y a plus que des communautés une
société personnes souffrant d'une
société mois en signant une société qui
manque de variété de ma poule b vous
dénoncez la société où les tensions sont
arrivés 3 jean castex
pas
[Applaudissements]
ce projet nous a légué aux ni l'éthique
majorité parlementaire open humaine
you plus générale il peut soit résident
de tout enfant d'avant d'intérim mais
elle piétine les faits en les rendant
superflue pour l'heure se font prier si
les maires en plaidant que la maternité
2009 due forme de contrats niveau d
artaud la place unique la place
extraordinaire mais meyer n'a abouti
ce projet de loi dominés les hommes
c'est l'espoir de dieu le bénisse les
beach boys qui vous trahissent et les
enfants les hommes et les femmes
vous êtes l'été d'istres dernière
[Applaudissements]
c'est 1 700 maternité et paternité il
n'y a pas de fatalité
super maman qui ne cesse de parler de
fraternité et qu'elle va falloir
respecter la paternité et la maternité
[Applaudissements]
ce projet doit penser que consacre si la
loi du plus fort en voulant autoriser
des apprentis sorciers et des embryons
humains génétiquement modifiés les
hommes chimay
ray tanguay d'hypothétiques d'intérêt
scientifique ont laissé ses enfants des
sorciers et expérimenté sur l'être
humain manipuler le génome humain
mais l'urgence écologique mis la crise
comme la vie volume de l'offre les yeux
manette toutes les évidences il refuse
de voir la réalité de notre humanité
il refuse de voir comme de la zone
dévastée la planète l'instant l'intérim
[Applaudissements]
la réalité c'est qu'il n'y a pas pris la
manade celui qui ne veut pas voir
solide et sommes solides et par semaine
oui folie lors de l'examen cet effet
l'assemblée nationale s'achèvent les
sénateurs qui dans quelques semaines
quelques mois auront à travailler en ce
projet de loi dans le contexte
d'aujourd'hui
des millions de nos concitoyens voient
leurs emplois jeunes ici ouvrons perdre
des milliers d'artisans de commerçants
et de patrons de pme se mêleront
malheureusement par des conséquences de
la crise sanitaire
mais ils se sont occupés cet été d'après
pierre sansen jeux pour tous deux vers
la trentaine de repas l'antichambre de
la gp12 manipulations génétiques de
création de leur artificier de
fécondation de c
ciel voilà sur quoi monsieur dupont
moretti laissant travailler
quelle honte
[Applaudissements]
mes soins de sa gloire de son texte
d'équilibré alors le gouvernement n'a
pas soutenu ces dérives de dérives et
grâce à vous ce sont déjà des mesures la
porte m la global des pays
définitivement vous
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire retiendra de cet été et nous
verrons la suite que pendant que la
france 2-0 frage comme sur l'orchestré
du titanic les députés jouer de la
musique aveugle à ce que tout se passait
ainsi vous sort de leurs concitoyens qui
se noyait il est permis
nous descendons ici un palier et partout
en france j'arrive de banquier et 2005
est tout seul incident
[Applaudissements]
ils entendent c'est le respect de
l'autre le respect de nos vies le
respect de leur intégrité personnelle et
familiale
nous nous attendions détracteurs la cour
s'est construit l'avion qui s'est posé
des limites à ses propres désirs
nana qui respecte celui qu'il dit aimer
la cour sous condition qu'elles sont en
gras qui subit soi même là vous généreux
soyons fiers de défendre et de protéger
la tour la justice l'égalité entre tous
les enfants
soyez en sûr qu'on y pense modène
si boonen que certains ne le comprennent
pas encore ce que nous sentons nous
dépasse aussi mais pour les plus
vulnérables ne lâche rien et tout pas
nous cacher doutez pas
[Applaudissements]
ne restez pas laisser vos commentaires
mais aussi de pouvoir
locales et de leurs proches et plus au
plus vite la famille et la filiation
secondes un nouveau protégé de notre
beau pays mais aussi aux quatre coins du
monde comme nous le disons souvent la
dignité des enfants
la dignité des femmes et des hommes n'a
pas de frontières c'est pourquoi de
paris des nations unies je vous assure
de notre engagement à relayer l'autre
femme pour la famille quéveau les
enfants
[Applaudissements]
les dames entre nous demos merci à tous
[Musique]
oh
une petite annonce un petit garçon qui
s'appellera trick qui a 5 ans a perdu
ses parents et les errements les
boutiques au pied de la colonne
d'abord messi messi errance à ses
parents
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le continent
le mystère n'a rien n'est arrêté
d'options nous restons déterminés il
faut qu'il devienne way
[Musique]
à
il était
allez
et
non
il est ici
jg
à caen
à
[Applaudissements]
g
ici escalettes
coc
janvier
m
gisèle
à temps
charpy
cher
et tout ça
ici
attendre
et
questions à m
je suis
il
ebodé
[Applaudissements]
allez
la madame
c'est sûr
tricolore
et
je fais
là
j'sais pas
le
la vérité
[Applaudissements]
enfin
le sol
à
quoi hélas
m
maman
en
non
à
et
[Musique]
oh
ah ah
[Musique]
inutile que du public était trop nous
répondons que ce crime inégalités pour
l'enfant c'est de passer d'une passe
avant la paix
il dit qu elle nous regarde pas nous
déplorons que la concerne tout le monde
elle s'applique à tous et il est de
notre responsabilité qu'elles soient
justes et des droits des plus faibles
il alors que le dow ne faut trop près
nous répondons tu confonds progrès
humain est une occasion technique
quand
quels sont-ils sur 10 nous démontrons
que les besoins du peuple tout temps
forts sont toujours les mêmes et
qualités de l'homme ne cherche toi
il dit qu'il était contre des enfants
nous répondons quel amour commence par
le respect de l'eau que les désirs
et qu'il n'ya pas de dreux
alors pas
tu le sais pas trop
nous l'avons tous les cinémas
jamais les tic
[Applaudissements]
on l'avait ma peau
enfin le bas nous sommes nous on pense
laurence je t'attends
le mot
messager
à
bon
déjà
chiche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'état
m
c'est trop cher des minéraux servier en
interpellant
connaissez si je travaille son combat
acharné comme un jeu quand le vide se
dit dans les manifs pour tous athées
les crèches
et
chez des amis une fois malgré les
difficultés
ecoutez jean mon sens il me contexte
sanitaire où j'ai déjà vous avez répondu
présent non seulement ici à paris place
vendôme mais aussi dans plus de 60
villes de france de lille
le bayonnais
et jusqu à fort de france
la manifestation commencera dans
quelques minutes alors merci pour votre
mobilisation battra pas mais d'étendre
vos missions réveiller les consciences
et construire une société durable
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui
tu es jacques brel de ses cendres grâce
à tous ceux qui se lèvent pour la santé
l'écologie nous avons réussi à bloquer
le nombre
à commencer par la paire à son père qui
figurait déjà corrigé dans le projet
pointe au virage
et qu'il en aille mieux
[Musique]
puis en 2014
mobilisés lors d'une manifestation de
pixels ce qui a eu pour effet d'antan et
politique du saint à l'eso
et donc c'est cette pratique est en
parler quand tu ligne rouge est franchie
centre et la droite maintenant on a les
mêmes incohérences
c est notre mobilisation contre le
projet de loi qui utilise la même marche
aux entrants
si pour effet de ralentir
considérablement le processus législatif
est d'obtenir le retrait de cet été il
incarne comme la rémanence porte m
la roja il est corrompu été acquis par
son cher ami
quand je vois vos visages à chaque
manifestation et logiciels sont dans ce
travail quotidien nous paye
communication avec la presse sur les
réseaux sociaux de rencontres avec les
parlementaires univers et dur passe
savante passe est marqué par un projet
et ça ce n'est pas pour regarder
oui la jeunesse a choisi son combat pour
la jeunesse a décidé d'assumer ses
responsabilités en s'engageant
durablement une société plus juste et
plus fraternel oui me cacher ses côtés
et encore en spéciale pour la famille
prévenue de solidarité comme nous
la confirmation
oui la jeunesse loin des défilés
gugusses cullers de soi disant fériste
au sein desquels la moyenne d'âge est
disons le bien différente
chers amis nous avons encore beaucoup de
travail devant nous mais nous y sommes
prêts et le seul petit mais vous le
savez chalon va devoir continuer à voir
le retrait visant à poursuivre votre
agacement au sein de nos équipes nous a
dit que je tiens à remercier les membres
pour avoir rendu possible la réalisation
de près de 60 manifestations
des conditions sanitaires mattingly
exigences du gouvernement continue je
pense que les délégués
[Applaudissements]
on guettait 10,4 notre action dérange et
la peinture quand je suis trop gras ça
alors
à mon tour de bras
ces remerciements vous dira bientôt
parce que tous ensemble on a soit
revient jamais
[Applaudissements]
oui
m
[Applaudissements]
olé
l'idée c'est de mobiliser tous nos
processus dans le monde assure projet et
nous tiendrons cet engagement
le deuxième le deuxième set est de
libérer la france
m alors je remercie par avance de votre
aide
alors merci en quittant sa place de
partir du second petit nombre en gardant
toujours quelques existence avec vos
voisins ne pas faire un bouchon sur les
sentiers vous pouvez sentir parvenant à
l'opéra vers le sud vers la scène et
donc voilà de sortir plus souvent joué
continuer à confiner de la place mais la
manifestation est terminée
et nous vous donnons rendez vous
pour les prochaines mobilisations
[Applaudissements]
m
c
enfermé
vous quittez
car
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
6 heures
m
[Applaudissements]
pas donné
ah ah
à
m
penser
cl
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
mais
[Musique]
peu y arrive au lit
hélas
bush
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on parle peu
comme il adore briller
[Musique]
chapeau
rapide
là où on allait
à
[Musique]
passée les
en est un
leberquier
8 heures
là
ça va
si la riche de tous
ce matin
[Musique]
rien
voilà
m
[Musique]
ma mère a fait fort
elle avait parlé
grâce à lui
m
[Musique]
hier
oh
m
le temps joue pour nous
alors établi
la news ça
ah ah
il ya une mineure et pour le coup là
vas-y vas-y attraits sont là des données
techniques
dans le raisonnement
[Musique]
ouais les autres maps et salut
ok je vais devoir tombe m'appelle on a
de chance
c'est bon a lancé durant ces violences
ouais
à l'instant l'aïe a admis le bâtisseur
secondes
voilà bah non
[Musique]
à
johnny va être précieux
[Musique]
et